[Musique]
notre sandwich géant
alors pour faire un goûter
extraordinaire mais un vrai goûté on va
prendre un pain de mie les pipes va
faire une énorme sandwich qui va être
entre anges comme ça est recouvert d'une
crème extraordinaire et qu'on va laisser
au réfrigérateur pour que ça devienne
glacée et quand on va le coupait ensuite
en tranches il va y avoir du crabe il va
y avoir du jambon avec du poulet il va y
avoir des cacahuètes avec du fromage ça
va être très très bon alors on va le
faire alors tu vois le pain de mie parce
que ça c'est très important la nuit il
faut non pas le couper en tranches comme
tu le couteau mais d'habitude c'est à
dire comme ça mais dans le sens de la
longueur
je vous le fais pas faire ça parce que
quand même j'ai tout petit peu peur mais
le boulot je vous le fera lui même très
bien si vous lui demandez alors après tu
m'en remettre ça ça et ça ça fait une
chose est là donc
alors voyons gilles veux tu s'il te
pleurer avec le beurre toutes les choses
à face à claire nous rien de très
important
il nous faut un morceau pour le poulet
tu vas t'en se sert de moi personne ne
voit
[Musique]
on
alors tu sais ce poulet donc je sais pas
comment tu vas faire à la maison pour
avoir incarné poulet pour ce goûter mais
je te donne un conseil la veille tu
demandes à te faire cuire ont pourri
pour leur part quand le poulet fini qui
comprend deux parties j'ai très faim
aujourd'hui est partie en cash ce soit
sous tente alors le matin le matin tu
vas t'on poule est tout près de faire
sauter bon alors là tu as continué puis
ensuite il va couper le jambon de la
même façon dans le même vol et un oeuf
dur qui voient leur dire qui est
relative à la coupe est également enquis
morceau n'importe comment comme ça et
qui vous mélangez tout ça ensemble
tu as bien travaillé dix d'angil s'est
terminée dans alors est ce que tu aimes
le crav n'aime pas le rap c'est
merveilleux le seul petit enfant qui
n'aiment pas le crabe on l'a aujourd'hui
avec nous regardez le le voilà gilles
filet forbid ça fait rien tu vas tu que
tu peux quand même le couper en morceaux
so what
parce qu'au milieu du crâne d'une petite
chose comme ça c'est rien et tu vas
continuer à faire tout ça est dans la
boîte de crabes qui n'oublie pas qu'il
ya de l'eau et c'est tout tu dois pas la
mettre là par les dauphins sassus foetus
est clair ton poulain
[Musique]
du coup je pense mais qui morceau
également
[Musique]
eh bien le crabe est terminée l'anti
c'est dans ce crabe est ce qu'on va
faire on va également y rajouter la
mayonnaise bien sûr et puis un tout
petit peu de salade h et à la soul a
lâché toute façon c'est pas très
difficile à terre mais je ne voudrais
pas que vous ayez comme excuse d'arrivée
la première semaine à l'école avec un
doigt bandits parce que ça n'existe pas
à la fin de l'année je le ferai tout
couper ouais on va mettre un tout petit
peu de mayonnaise dans la mayonnaise
c'est pas la peine de la faire vous même
il ya de la manade de la meilleure
raison tube de la mayonnaise en rambo qu
en boîte c'est aussi bon et ça va aussi
bien pour ça un jour on fera de la
mayonnaise mais un autre jour alors ici
également mettre tout petit peu de
mayonnaise tous les deux vous à les
mélanger
mélange avec
audi dans sa marche mélange bien te
manque un tout petit peu de mayonnaise
je crois est ce que tu aimes la tomate
mais quelque chose parce que ça s'est un
peu pas là on va se mettre un petit peu
de tomates pour l'est pour le goût tout
petit peu aussi
alors là ici j'ai du fromage fondu au
match tombe du double crème du ciel
fromage pour tartiner comme ça alors on
a acheté beau nick beau ce fromage ans
va le mettre dans un bol et ajouter un
tout petit peu de crème fraîche et voir
deux cuillères
et on va écraser tout ça jusqu'à ce que
ça devienne une pâte molle
gilles tout à l'heure quand tu as fait
quand tu as des fessées cacahuètes en
morceaux j'ai l'impression que tu as
mangé dans man on man
aucune ça m'étonne autant d'amis qu'il
était bien j'étais en donner je te
permet de la faire
alors c'est caca watts on en est
seulement la moitié
là et on va y rester une cuillère voilà
le sandwich est prêt alors qu'est ce
qu'on met dessous on met le le tram
alors bien et anton crav là dessus 33
étant le là c'est pas la peine de tous m
puisqu'on en fera d'autres fruits etc
années quand même une épaisseur
[Musique]
sur une seule sur une scène tout moment
parce qu'on va mettre l'autre dessus
temps légal
[Musique]
c'est vraiment bon alors tout ça on va
le garder pour les autres fans de
nirvana sur une plaque en clair au
milieu tu verrais m les cacahuètes
mélanger avec le chômage
[Musique]
aussi ça dépasse un peu c'est pas grave
c'est la première tu comprends alors
dessus en remet le pain est là alors là
nous allons mettre ton poulet
[Musique]
vous
maintenant on met la dernière tranche de
pain dessus c'est beaucoup et avec tout
le fromage qui nous restent qui est là
qui a été vue d'une fourchette
vous allez tartiner ce fromage comme ça
sur tous les côtés
[Musique]
et sur le dessus allez-y
alors toi tu perds tu prends bien sûr
tout de suite la simplicité un thé
commence par l'un des styles assez
facile ça va c'est donc tout seul je
vais le finir un tout petit peu parce
que c'est jamais que la rente pour les
vacances c'est l'été les vacances n'est
pas encore tout à fait rodez à côté de
bordeaux là mon pays je vous conseille
toujours de le changer de place parce
que si vous le laissez sur ce plat le
fromage qui va redevenir très dur m'a
collé un message collé au fond du plat
l'on pourra pas lent sortir aller
apporter ça
et maintenant la vaisselle aller à la
vaisselle tout le monde
faut tout nettoyer validant les attentes
quoique les éclats tous les deux dans le
réfrigérateur
vous avez fini l'art et celle bravo
allez vous pouvez l'ouvrir on va quand
même coûté ses 100 bougies
attention ce n'est le bien bon alors si
je comprends bien nous sommes trois
alors qui sait qu'ils ont une grosse
tranche soutient aucun comme ça
tiens tes trois parfums le crabe les
cacahuètes et le jambon gilles un tout
petit il faut dire qu'il a mangé toutes
les cacahuètes entre temps enfin ça
c'est tout petit c'est trop petit ça
c'est pour le pour le bébé qu'elle agit
là voilà et bien tout le reste c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]